[Music]
[Applause]
a mike renner pro football focus lead
draft analyst co-host of the tailgate
podcast head over to pro football
pff.com use the promo code pff30 for 30
off any pff subscriptions i want to talk
about quarterbacks but i want you to go
back to last year though mike and where
was zach wilson on your radar where was
mac jones on your radar these are guys
who are starting week one in the nfl
because it feels like every year we
happen upon somebody and we go where did
they come from so
let's go back to where you had zach
wilson and mack jones a year ago
they're on the radar for sure they were
not super high on that radar though mack
jones obviously we saw him towards the
end after tool went down
there was a guy on our staff for our
college guy seth galena who said you
know he could end up as an actual
quarterback prospect i didn't think he
had the tools zach wilson obviously had
that shoulder injury did not have a good
sophomore year he was actually more
thought of highly as a prospect by us
back after his freshman year so i think
he kind of hit the nail on the head here
there's like this trend of guys coming
out of nowhere um and i think it's kind
of how quarterback development has been
uh at the younger ages uh nowadays it
doesn't kind of take that long four-year
starter to actually establish yourself
as this real deal quarterback prospect i
said this numerous times last season
that mac jones was making it look too
easy
the regular seasons just making it look
too easy and then i i thought well okay
you got a you got a running back first
rounder you got offensive line first
rounders wide receivers first rounders
is he any good
i i wasn't i don't know if i'm still
sure how good he is
but
he there's something to be said about
how easy he made it look last year
that is the
sort of million-dollar question that
everyone's trying to figure out in
quarterback evaluations how do you
separate what the quarterback's doing
from what the offense and the town
around him is doing and
it's very easy to hit
guys who are wide open
a lot of quarterbacks can do that with
wide open pockets with three feet in
every direction to work with
but it's what can you do to go above and
beyond that and i think we almost
underate or a lot of people underrated
the fact that mac jones was kind of he
was creating some of that space in his
own he would look off linebackers he
would hold safeties he would do the
things that
it's difficult to sort of quantify and
you see a guy running wide open
sometimes that's on the quarterback for
like i said holding a safety or getting
this creating space himself and mack
jones did that better than any other
quarterback in class last year maybe
even
if not trevor lawrence right up there
with him so i think that did get
underrated and you're seeing that in the
preseason now all right if the draft
were held today
the first quarterback taken
absolutely positively no doubt is
there's no trevor lawrence in this
year's class
but to me it's spencer rattler the
oklahoma quarterback
obviously lincoln riley develops
quarterbacks there as good as anyone
else in the country and his talent is
just off the charts and just what he can
do not only physically with his legs as
a runner but just outside the pocket arm
talent he kind of takes that
sort of
play-making ability that everyone's
looking for that out-of-structure stuff
that mahomes is known for that aaron
rodgers is known for he takes that to
the extreme he was the highest grade
quarterback by us here at pfff outside
the pocket last year he is looking to do
that almost first he's kind of the
definition of a gen z quarterback where
the the attention span is not there he
wants to break the pocket he wants to
just start making plays uh and he
consistently does it in that oklahoma
offense yeah but he got benched last
year
i know i watched him when he started and
i was like
as i remember watching him in high
school
because he had nico manion the
basketball player i think was on his uh
high school football team like they he
was like wow this guy is awesome and
then he goes to oklahoma and i'm
thinking he ain't awesome
he became better a lot better last year
but see that's just it like it's it's
rolling the dice if you would have said
at the beginning of last year that guy
is going to be the first quarterback
taken i would have went got talent i
don't know if he's going to be
consistent enough
that's the thing it's at this point
these guys aren't to the level of trevor
lawrence they're not to the level of
even justin fields was coming into his
last year college um but the talent is
there and that's kind of what you're
based off of it's the things that he's
kind of doing and excelling at you can't
really teach and the sort of inside the
pockets staying within structure you can
develop that more you can't develop a
guy to throw it 50 yards on a dime
running to his right which we've seen
radley do multiple times okay so spencer
rattler out of oklahoma
the second quarterback off the board if
the draft for today would be
sam howell north carolina another guy
who's very talented i mean he might have
the strongest arm in the country uh him
or military from liberty right up there
they both have throws in their tape that
are 60 plus yards and not not super sky
balls he's throwing it on the line
almost physically looks like baker
mayfield just a shade over six foot
about 215
can make some plays as a runner but
that north carolina offense why we're
not kind of putting them in that you
know that conversation of trevor
lawrence like his surefire lock number
one is that through more rpos than
anyone else in the country last year he
threw more gold balls than anyone else
in the country and not that not saying
that he won't have to do those at the
nfl level but those are one read
basically not having to do quarterback-y
things it's just arm talent at that
point so the arm talent's there physical
tools are there to to end up as number
one overall pick it's just we need to
see him actually operate an offense
there at north carolina more all right
the third quarterback off the board is
here's where it gets a little hairy i
think those two are the top two clearly
the guy i like is the third quarterback
off the board is the kai guy touchdown
just there malik willis from liberty uh
trey lance goes number three overall
this past year basically based off of
what he can do physically uh not much
sort of
polished as a quarterback not much sort
of even
experienced as a quarterback trade land
that's kind of malik willis at liberty
he was a former auburn guy lost out to
bone knicks but he he said might have
the strongest arm in the country and is
the best runner in the country he had
over a thousand yards rushing last year
is six foot 225 and runs a 4-5 like he
had
more broken tackles than a lot of the
running backs drafted last year this guy
could be a running back in the nfl if he
wanted to would be a probably third
fourth rounder if you just wanted to
play that and that's going to play so
much and has been playing so much with
guys like calamari lamar jackson how it
impacts defenses so i do think that
even if malik willis doesn't necessarily
develop too much as a passer just what
he can do from a rushing perspective is
going to show him get him drafted highly
he's mike renner the pro football focus
lead draft analyst uh let me throw out a
couple other names jt daniels of georgia
high on him
not yet you will go back and watch the
cincinnati so he
comes in end of last year i think he
played five games i want to say
the first few
electric i mean he's bombing it down the
football field but then you watch him go
up against a good defense so he didn't
actually face any of the top sort of
competition in the ssc when he does come
in was a good defense in cincinnati and
basically doesn't know when to stop
taking chances with the football had one
the highest average depths of target of
any quarterback in college football last
year over 12 yards down the football
field he's just throwing almost willy
nilly and you see that in the bowl game
where he's just taking all these bad
chances and necessarily
not really reading the defenses first so
still too early i'd say for him but he
was the he was qb3 in that class behind
trevor lawrence and justice fields
coming out of high school obviously a
massively talented dude but we just need
to see a more consistent quarterback
this year key don slovis at usc i don't
think he has a great arm but i think
he's really accurate i don't know and
he's got good size i think six two six
three what do you think of slovis
yeah he's the guy that needs that mac
jones sort of leap to basically playing
perfect football because no one's going
to draft him first overall based off of
what he brings the table physically and
he said the arm is not great but
you know joe burrow's arm wasn't great
you went number one overall but when it
is not great you have to play flawless
you have to not make mistakes with the
football and i think that's what
slovis has just done too much of at this
point throw the ball of the other team
basically
missing linebackers missing reads and
that sort of thing that you can't do but
he
he does have the sort of the processing
ability you see him get to his
checkdowns quickly you see him get your
second reads very quickly he has that
ability but just too many sort of
boneheaded plays so far i know uh
carson's strong at nevada
that he lives up to his name you know
he's a big kid but he's at nevada
how did somebody who's maybe a
first-round draft pick end up at nevada
i actually haven't looked too much into
his recruiter background why he ended up
there but
it is surprising because not only is he
you know playing good football
quarterback position he's got a cannon
and he's got a very
aesthetically pleasing release it's like
kind of like aaron rodgers release where
it's just like it's quick it looks like
the way a football should be thrown
that's carson strong um and so i think
he could end up in that first round
conversation obviously played
exceptionally well last year has a
pretty good wide receiver out there and
romeo dubs who could be in the first
strong conversation as well that
he's going to play some real competition
this year i believe he plays boise state
early on plays cal early on
yeah play some play some actual you know
d1 competition after not playing any
excuse me power five competition after
not playing any last year but carson
strong i think he had the most
completions of anyone and by far that
came 50 plus yards downfield last year
and had the farthest throw in the
country from start to finish 70 yards
from his hand to where the ball ended up
of any quarterback in the country last
year i'll throw out another one it's
only because a scout told me about him
can he pick it at pittsburgh
can he pick it
he's got so there's a lot of guys with
cannons in this draft class not a guy in
a lot of guys who are polished though he
is all over the place with his accuracy
so far like he'll he'll have throws that
are just
i mean gorgeous gorgeous throws he
reminds me a lot of the guy who might be
starting for the colts or jacob easton
uh back at washington where it's just
like man that is 40 yard laser post and
then the next one is a bubble screen
that sailed over a guy's head so pickett
has the physical ability but man he is
accuracy issues for days
you got some good games coming up this
weekend will we see a surprise in
college football
i mean you would definitely see a
surprise if you asked me to predict a
surprise that it's not my forte i am not
i am not the best prognosticator but uh
my
my upset pick there is any upset pick i
think georgia comes out george is my one
of my national championship picks i
think they come out and put it to
clemson because this is the most
talented defense in the country right
now and yeah clemson's ranked three
georgia's ranked five but i think on a
neutral field give me georgia on that
one
mike good to talk to you we'll be
talking to you during the season thank
you very much
for sure thanks for having me on dan
have a good one that's mike renner pro
football focus lead draft analyst i will
say that mike does make me feel better
about my questions
when i go uh who's your upset special
this weekend
like he gives it great thought i
appreciate that